on days like today I really do feel
sorry for the public for you guys
essentially trying to keep up with AI
news and the kind of questions you might
have did openai just automate my job
with operator who knows you're probably
thinking it's $200 and it's really hard
to get past those clickbait headlines
did the US government just invest half a
trillion dollars into a Stargate what
the hell is that I heard China just
caught up to the West in AI with
something called Deep seek and why
people talking about Humanity's last
exam so to try to help a little bit I'm
going to cover the nine developments of
the last 100 hours honestly if not
exhaustively yes of course I read the
Deep seek paper in full and have spent
hours testing the open aai operator as
well as the perplexity assistant and all
the rest in case you're wondering yes I
did edit this perplexity response first
up in this listicle video is of course
open AI operator and it's kind of decent
it's okay you have to use a VPN if
you're not in the US and honestly I
wouldn't do that for the functionality I
would do it if you want to kind of get a
sense of where agents are going just
straight up front though I can tell you
that it's nowhere close to automating
any kind of job for two major reasons
one is it often gets stuck in these kind
of Loops where it attempts these same
kind of basic failed plan again and
again it's not essentially smart enough
to get itself out of these kind of basic
loops the second big reason is because
of open ai's own impositions on what the
model can't do understandable
impositions I tried about 20 random
tasks and the truth is you can never
fully relax you always have to keep
going back to the system and saying yes
proceed and no you can't manually hard
override that you can't put it in the
prompt not to ask permission then of
course many sites have captures that you
have to manually take over and input I'm
pretty certain if you iterate again and
again on a prompt you can develop a
workflow that you could save on the top
right and share and maybe save a little
bit of time for certain tasks at the
moment though if I'm being honest it is
a bit of a stretch to say that it's
useful but if we step back you can see
where all of this is going this operator
has a ton of safeguards that might slow
it down but people will just migrate to
ones that don't have those safeguards
ones where downloading files is easier
and captures are done for you that will
be great for usability but not so great
for the dead internet Theory then
there's just Flatout mistakes I read the
system card in full for open AI operator
and it was quite revealing the operator
is known to make quote irreversible
mistakes like sending an email to the
wrong recipient or having an incorrectly
dated reminder for the user to take
their medication and yes they did reduce
those mistakes but not eliminate them
also when I talked about those
confirmations that the model asked
before proceeding to The Next Step that
happens most times
but not every time sometimes the
operator just goes ahead and does it
which is a good thing or a bad thing
depending on your perspective you'll be
quite glad I guess to know that when
it's asked to do things like make
banking transactions it refuses at a
rate of around 94% then you might be
wondering what about if the operator
navigates to a malicious site that's
trying to trick the operator well there
was one time where it did so and didn't
notice that it was doing so open AI are
aware of this though and have an extra
layer of safety on top called a prompt
injection monitor checking to see if
sites are trying to trick the operator
and it did catch this concerning example
but there's one problem it too fails
around 1% of the time they of course
commit to rapidly updating it in
response to newly discovered attacks but
there is a slim chance things could go
wrong at every layer in my last video if
you remember I gave you early leaked
results on its performance in various
computer us benchmarks and web browsing
benchmarks but remember it uses Chain of
Thought to Think Through what it should
do at each stage it monitors the screen
taking screenshots and then decides now
whenever you hear a Chain of Thought
think rapid Improvement in the near
future if we get a widely accessible or
open-source agent this year say from
China that gets 80% 90% on computer use
benchmarks like this one then the
internet is going to change forever fun
fact by the way the system prompt lies
to the model and encourages the model to
lie it tells the model it has 20 years
of experience in using a computer and it
says if you recognize someone while
using the computer say browsing an image
you should not identify them just say
you don't know even if you do know that
person personally can't see any problem
with encouraging models to lie but
anyway we have to get to the next story
the story is a quick one which is the
announcement yesterday of the perplexity
assistant for Android I immediately
downloaded and tried it out obviously
it's much smarter than something like
Siri and I've been using it to play very
particular songs or specific YouTube
videos but there's a slight problem at
the moment it's not quite smart enough
it doesn't understand commands like play
me the latest video from the YouTube
channel AI explain now for a story that
many people think is bigger than agents
as big as it gets half a trillion
dollars into project Stargate except
it's kind of not really half a trillion
dollars it's definitely a hundred
billion do which was kind of reported on
a while back I even did a video on it
and the rest is all promises mind you
$100 billion is still a hell of a lot of
money and that will get you a lot of big
beautiful buildings in Sam's words or
massive data centers you don't build
that in other words unless you think AI
is going to radically transform Society
by promised size of investment we're
talking about something on the scale of
the Manhattan Project as a fraction of
GDP the analogy of course of building a
nuclear bomb is appropriate at least
least in terms of its ambiguity because
even though project Stargate according
to the US president is going to be quote
great for jobs and according to samman
incredible for the country let's not
pretend that for many of the companies
investing in this project one of the
first things they would do with an AGI
is cut down on labor costs Sam Alman has
himself directly predicted as much many
many times over the years including
fairly recently he said things like the
cost of Labor will go to zero and he
expects massive INE quality now
obviously the Boost to shareholder value
will be amazing and there will be other
upsides according to Larry Ellison one
of the key investors in Project Stargate
and what's that you ask well AI
surveillance the police will be on their
best behavior because we Rec we we're
constantly recording watching and
recording everything that's going on
citizens will be on their best behavior
because we're constantly recording and
Reporting everything that's going on uh
um and it's un it's unimpeachable I'm
not the only one by the way who is a
little bit concerned about the downsides
of that kind of surveillance this was
anthropic CEO Dario amid's reaction to
the news of Stargate at the end of this
Bloomberg article he said I'm very
worried about 1984 scenarios or worse if
I were a predicting man I would say that
that would first come to a place like
China and only later to the west but
that's cold comfort basically to spell
it out and imagine every text message
and email being monitored by a massive
AGI llm for signs of subversion of
course there are doubters of Stargate
including curiously Microsoft who
weren't there at the announcement
apparently their Executives have been
studying whether building such large
data centers for openai would even pay
off in the long run speaking of
anthropic the next story is a quick one
because it's just a rumor but it's from
a pretty reliable source delm Patel of
semi analysis says that anthropic have a
model that is better than 03 if you're
not sure what o03 is I've done a video
on it but it's a model that broke
various benchmarks in mathematics and
coding and is the smartest model that's
known currently although it's not
publicly released yet Google's already
got a reasoning model anthropic
allegedly has one internally that's like
really good better than 03 even but you
know we'll see um when they eventually
release it like it's like now though for
the story that many of you have been
waiting for which is deep seek R1 the
model out of China that shocked many in
the west deep seek for those who don't
know is kind of a side project of a
Chinese Quant trading firm and yet
they've produced a model that's more or
less as good as the best that AGI labs
in the west have come up with it's not
quite as good in my opinion but it is
massively cheaper to use and no one I
don't think was expecting them to catch
up as quickly as they have done and to
give you more of a sense of context the
likely budget for the entire deep seek
R1 model and the entire deep seek team
is likely less than the annual salary of
certain CEOs of AI labs in the west
whose models underperform deep seek R1
at least according to the Benchmark
figures which you've got to admit look
pretty tall and impressive and by the
way I don't think these numbers are
faked if this model had been released
100 days ago it would definitely have
counted as the best model in the world
and I don't rule out the possibility
that deep seat comes out with a model
that's better than any other model
around this year especially in domains
like mathematics and on certain science
benchmarks not likely but possible if
you're wondering by the way it got 30.9%
on my own Benchmark a test of basic
reasoning capacity that again would have
been the best in the world just a few
months ago now I am going to get to the
detail of How It's Made in a moment but
first some wider comments on what it
means first people keep calling it open
source but it's not fully open source
they didn't release the data set behind
the model they did say that deep seek R1
was using the base model deep seek V3
which was trained on around 15 trillion
tokens but they don't say what those
tokens were in other words we don't
really know about the training data so
it's not fully open source back to deep
seek R1 though and you might be
wondering didn't the US impose sanctions
on China so they couldn't use Advanced
chips like the b00 for example from
Nvidia yes they did but that might have
had the unintended side effect of
forcing Chinese AI companies to be more
Innovative with what they've got in
other words there is a chance that those
chip sanctions actually have brought
China to being competitive with the West
in AI the next comment is on the sheer
acceleration this will unleash because
it is mostly open- sourced anyone
including rival companies like meta can
copy what deeps seek have done indeed
according to one possible leak R1
massively outperforms llama 4 which
isn't yet released from meta and so
they're just dropping everything and
copying what deep seek have done of
course this is unconfirmed but the
principle is still the same it's almost
like deeps R1 is now the minimum
performance cuz anyone can just copy it
that's of course bad news and good news
for safety depending on how you look at
it on the one hand governance and
control of AI look set to be borderline
hopeless one very respected figure
formerly of Google deepmind and open AI
said when asked what is the plan after
deep seek for AGI safety he said there
is no plan but on the other hand some
have welcomed the fact that safety
researchers can now inspect the chains
of thought behind deep seek R1 in a way
they couldn't have done with 01 or 03
that's of course great for safety
testers like Apollo research whom I
interviewed three of them just a couple
of days ago for AI Insiders on my
patreon and if you're wondering why
studying R1 might be important is
because the model emits chains of
thought before answering like the O
Series of models from open AI we can can
only see summaries of those thoughts for
the O Series but with R1 we see
everything so we can better study when
the models might be scheming which is
what we covered in this interview all of
which gets us to how deep seek R1 was
trained in the first place and
summarizing this 22-page paper full of
research is going to be difficult but
I'm going to try and do it in one or two
paragraphs of course this will be
oversimplifying but here we go so start
with the base model deep seek V3 which
they had already made then let's kick
things off with some lovely long Chain
of Thought examples to give the model a
cold start now you can skip that stage
and go straight to reinforcement
learning but they found the training to
be a bit unstable unpredictable anyway
having fin tune the base model on that
cold start data it's time to move to the
next stage reinforcement learning we're
going to test the model repeatedly in
verifiable domains like mathematics and
code rewarding it whenever it gets a
correct outcome not correct individual
steps and we'll get to that later but
the correct outcome also we need to
throw in some fine-tuning on correct
outputs that follow the right format in
the appropriate language the format
being always thinking first in tags and
then answering afterwards then rinse and
repeat this RL and fine-tuning this time
with some quote non- reasoning data
let's bring in some wider domains like
factuality and quote self-cognition all
of these correct outputs and fine-tuning
data that we're Gathering by the way can
of course be used for distilling smaller
smarter models anyway Bob's your uncle
do all of that and you get deep seek R1
of course I'm skipping Lots if it were
that easy then every company would have
done it but that's the basic idea and
did you notice how synthetic that
process is get the model to generate
chains of thought and then reinforce the
model on those outputs that led to a
correct answer they did not mandate
reflective reasoning or promote
particular problem solving strategies
they wanted to accurately observe the
model's natural progression during the
RL process it's the bitter lesson in
action don't hardcode human rules let
the models discover them for themselves
one of the things that the model teaches
Itself by the way is to Output longer
and longer responses to get better
results notice the average length of
response going up and up and up the more
it's trained kind of makes sense to
solve harder problems you need longer
outputs the models themselves learned
that they needed to self correct that's
not something inputed by researchers so
that's why the model constantly does
things like say wait wait wait in the
middle of responses and then change its
mind now what humans have learned is how
to quote jailbreak the model or get it
to do whatever you want it to do and if
that pequs your interest I've got an
arena for you that's the gray Swan Arena
which you can enter yourself and they
are the sponsors of today's video It's
All About testing whether you can
Jailbreak these models including the
very latest ones by the way you don't
have to be an AI researcher you could
just be a creative writer or hacker and
there are monetary rewards sometimes
you're even testing models that aren't
out yet and there is one competition
that is live as of today pretty much
every unreleased model can be jailbroken
and there are also leaderboards for
those who do it best as ever links in
the description the next story is of
great interest to me personally because
it pertains to the type of verifier they
use this part of the paper updated my
belief about how even 03 IS trained to
get the insane results in mathematics
that O3 did I thought every single
reasoning step had to be verified
otherwise just one miscalculation in an
entire Chain of Thought could undo all
the good work that's called process
reward modeling and that could still be
how o1 and 03 are trained but probably
not instead it looks more likely now
that it's simple outcome reward modeling
that's the approach that underperformed
in the original let's verify
step-by-step paper I should say many
famous researchers including franois
Chalet still believe that the O Series
performs a kind of search every step or
a verification step but the Deep seek
team said that step-by-step verification
adds additional computational overhead
it's also susceptible apparently to
reward hacking where the base model just
gets good at convincing the verifier
that it's passed in short it seems
simpler just to grade The Final Answer
not every single reasoning step and
here's another hint that it's a pure
form of RL than I initially suspected
this time from Sebastian bck of open AI
now it's really everything is kind of
emergent nothing is hardcoded it's
anything that you see you know out there
with the reasoning nothing has been done
to say to the model hey you should maybe
you know verify your solution you should
backtrack you should XYZ no tactic was
given to the model everything is
emerging everything is learned through
reinforcement learning this is in insane
Insanity at this point in the video I
want to point out a kind of whitewashing
done by open aai that I don't think
anyone else has noticed the O Series has
been celebrated by open aai for its
robustness for example just two days ago
in this paper great news for safety
apparently that the model can think for
longer before replying but I'm of course
old enough to remember when it was
supposed to be process reward modeling
that was good for safety when open AI
boasted that rewarding the thought
process itself rather than the outcome
is an encouraging sign for alignment
this was echoed by Sam Alman because it
was thought that we could review each
step in the process rather than just
look at the overall outcome if we just
rewarded the outcome which it seems like
we are now doing then the models would
get up to all sorts of shenanigans on
the way toward getting the outcome
instead if process supervision worked
best where we could scrutinize and
optimize each individual step we'd have
better scrutiny of the overall process
my question is if optimizing each
individual step in process supervision
is a positive sign for alignment what
does it say now that we're rewarding
outcomes shouldn't there be a new blog
post saying that outcome based
supervision has an important alignment
downside no it seems like we only get
the blog post if it seems good give up
on your dreams of producing a chain of
thought that is endorsed by humans this
is the kind of Chain of Thought summary
that I get for an English language
request a Chain of Thought in Spanish
which makes it a bit harder for me to
endorse I've also seen many chains of
thought of course in Mandarin this kind
of language mixing by the way was of
course foreseen by people like Andrea
karpathy who said you can tell that
reinforcement learning is done properly
when the model cease to speak English in
their Chain of Thought why would English
or indeed ultimately any human language
be the optimum way to do step-by-step
reasoning what happens if a model
proposes a solution to climate change
and we inspect their Chain of Thought
and it's just random characters it's a
bit harder to trust what's going on
indeed Demis saris CEO of Google
deepmind in an interview published
yesterday warned that he worried that
models would become deceptive and
underperform on tests of their malicious
capability pretend in other words not to
be able to produce a bioweapon also I
had noticed Demis sais changed his
timelines in recent months saying that
he expected AGI or super intelligence
within a decade if you guys have been
following my channel you'll know that he
gave deadline like 2034 well check this
out and I think one thing that's clearly
missing and I always always had as a
benchmark for for AGI was the ability
for these systems to invent their own
hypotheses or conjectures about science
not just prove existing ones so of
course that's extremely useful already
to prove an existing maths conjecture or
something like that or or play a game of
go to a world champion level but could a
system invent go could it come up with a
new rean hypothesis or could it come up
with relativity um back in the days that
Einstein did it with the information
that he had and I think today's systems
are still pretty far away from having
that kind of creative uh inventive
capability okay so a couple years away
till we hit AGI I think um you know I
would say probably like 3 to five years
away so if someone were to declare that
they've reached AGI in 2025 probably
marketing I think so almost every aico
in other words seems to be converging on
this 1 to 5e timeline why not this year
well let me try to give you a strange
anecdotal example models like deep seek
R1 have weird quirky reasoning flaws for
the purposes of testing this coding side
project I'm doing I asked deep seek R1
to come up with this multiple choice
quiz it had to meet certain parameters
and it failed to meet them but that
wasn't the real issue do you notice a
slight flaw with the multiple choice
answers It produced for these 25
questions let's just say that they are
somewhat biased towards answers B and C
here's my bigger question though will
these remaining reasoning blind spots
you could call them be filled as a
byproduct of continued scaling of say RL
or will they need to be patched one by
one if the former is the case we could
have AGI in those very short timelines
that the AI CEOs publicly predict now if
the latter scenario is the case that
they have to be patched one by one there
could be aggi denialists in 2030 and
Beyond we better to end the video then
than on quote Humanity's last exam I
don't regard this as a for AI but it is
an interesting new Benchmark I would say
the title is a little bit misleading
because the creators of The Benchmark
are working on another challenging
Benchmark which apparently takes groups
of humans days to complete so is even
harder some people have focused on the
fact that deep seek r one performs best
getting 99.4% on this hardest of the
hard benchmarks the truth is it's the
way they created The Benchmark they kept
testing models like 01 until they found
questions that 01 struggled on Because
deep seek R1 wasn't out yet they
couldn't do that kind of iteration on it
so it's not fully accurate to say that
it performs best because it is the
smartest model as far as I can see it
tests heavily obscure knowledge on
things like minute details of
hummingbird Anatomy now I will say that
a model getting say 90% on this
Benchmark will be amazing and incredible
and I would use that model but I don't
think it would be quite as impactful as
a model getting say 90% on an agency
Benchmark as I touched on at the
beginning of this video an agent
properly being able to do remote tasks
would transform the world economy the
New York Times reported that the
original name for this particular
Benchmark was Humanity's Last Stand so I
am glad they changed the title let's
hope it's not because I could see this
particular Benchmark being crushed by
the end of next year if not even this
year man that was a lot to cover in one
video so thank you so much for making it
to the end as I say I feel less sorry
for myself and more sorry for the public
who have to weigh through countless
random headlines to get to what's
actually happening I've tried to do my
best in this video but let me know what
you think as ever thank you so much for
watching and have a wonderful day